the U.S is preparing for possible war
with China that was the excuse the
Pentagon leaders gave for their new even
bigger defense budget of 842 billion
dollars that way the U.S can be ready to
attack China within days if needed this
budget sustains our current Readiness
and adapts The Joint Force to the Future
War fighting requirements this is a
matter of significant National Security
importance we must act with clear-eyed
urgency
by doing so no adversary should ever
underestimate the resolve of our nation
and the strength of our military
preparation for war deterring war is
extraordinarily expensive but it's not
as expensive as fighting a war and this
budget prevents war and prepares us to
fight it if necessary this comes as the
U.S is strengthening military ties with
Australia Japan and South Korea at this
rate is war with China inevitable